[Music]
so I'm really happy to be here to talk
about the work that I did with my
colleagues at at way up over the last
year and a half and you know sort of two
notes so first of all if you didn't
catch the tents I actually left way up a
week ago and have started on Monday at
teachers pay teachers here in New York
but I'm really you know proud of what my
co-workers and Iowa I put able to
accomplish over that time with a very
small team so I'm really thrilled to be
able to talk with you about that today
mmm yeah and you know as Robert said I
was the only full-time data scientist I
wore data engineering hat as well as I
mentioned briefly but the work that I'm
talking about wouldn't be possible
without my colleagues on the engineering
team who helped me build this system get
it into production alright so what I
want to talk about today is how some of
the constraints from the business and
the way that we've built the site as
well as the scale of the team very small
led to a bunch of decisions we made
around algorithms software architecture
tools as well as just in what order did
we tackle different things and that's
kind of be gonna be the theme throughout
the talk today so to ground you a little
bit about way up way up is the leading
platform for connecting college students
and young professionals to entry-level
jobs internships and part-time jobs and
it's important to know something about
the business model here so way up is a
company that gets its revenue from
companies that are looking for talent so
posting jobs on our job board in the
case of some of the larger companies
also getting other types of employment
branding solutions things like social
media blog posts and so forth so one of
the challenges if you are a maybe a
large old company is trying to convince
21 year olds that maybe have never heard
of you that they really want to go work
for Unilever which is a really good
company to work for so a lot of it is
trying to sort of to promote these
companies
to people who might not otherwise be
aware of them or beware of those
opportunities so in terms of the
technology we have this job board a mix
of jobs from way up customers as well as
jobs from other distributor sources from
yeah maybe feeds that you've heard of
and one of the other components of the
the system is sourcing so if when you
sign up on way up as a candidate as a
user you have a profile it's like a
really kind of millennial friendly
on-brand version of maybe your LinkedIn
profile kind of a similar idea and liked
in like LinkedIn you get messages from
employers who look at your profile and
so oh hey you should consider applying
to our jobs so from the point of view of
a user you know you're you know 21 years
old you're just graduating from college
you run across some branded content on
Instagram or something like that make
your way to way up com and what we do is
we have you fill out a profile using
what we call Mad Libs here approach to
get a lot of information about you so we
know your major or majors we know where
you went to college we know about your
job history we know all sorts of things
and all this happens in the first step
again to make it valuable for employers
to do this sourcing step as well so
after you filled out your profile then
you can come to the main jobs listing
page start browsing jobs applying for
them in many cases it's as simple as
clicking on an apply button to send your
profile to to these companies and so ok
you know kind of the first question is
recommender systems are a fair amount of
fiddly technology why would you want to
build one of these things in the first
place and there are a couple of really
good reasons so first of all you know
you guys me when we're looking for jobs
not that hard I basically type in the
title I had for my previous job and I
find lots of jobs that had the same
title if you're just coming out of
college if you're looking for an
internship you may have no idea what's
out there and so in that case it really
is beneficial to the users to hey find
some suggestions that might be nah-nah
yes and and make sure that people are
seeing those additionally like I just
said you just spent five minutes filling
out your profile you told us about what
you've done in the past you've told us
fun facts you've told us kind of your
major you really want to have a great
experience this isn't like Netflix which
we just heard about where it's fine if
you get a mix of you know romantic
comedies and samurai movies at the
beginning because you don't expect
Netflix to know anything about you but
for way up or a company like this where
you've told us a great deal you do have
those expectations and we should try to
meet them and of course way up is a
business and it would behoove us to
promote customer jobs maybe a little bit
on top of other jobs from distributors
that you should be applying to as well
and so for all these reasons it makes
sense to have a recommender system not
just be like indeed calm with the search
box okay so on top of those business
constraints and sate site design
constraints we also have scale
constraints you're not not developer
scale but actually technology scale so
at any given point in time way up has
about a hundred thousand job listings
that are available for it to recommend
and after you've finished filling out
all those Madlib steps to generate your
profile we've got on the order of like a
second to come up with recommendations
so this is not a batch job that's
running overnight to do collaborative
filtering or anything like that we
actually have to do this generation this
mismatching to recommend jobs really
really fast so we can't leverage you
know very slow processing we can't do
anything that requires interaction
history so any type thing like
collaborative filtering item item
recommendations you haven't looked at
any jobs yet we have to do something
different and we also can't do anything
that takes a lot of time over those
hundred thousand listings we have
something like ten microseconds per
listing which you know computers are
fast but so that's not a ton of time to
do something in in real time so a lot of
the the technology decisions are based
on this constraint as well and so yeah
that's all these together is it's a
fairly hard problem to
you to do well and I don't want to claim
that we're doing super well but
definitely made some good progress
so again constraint so far the business
model means we want to put the thumb on
the scale a little bit we want to
include any heuristics that we have
about what jobs might be appropriate to
you based on all the data that we have
any metadata about the jobs themselves
the profile before browsing means we
have to base the recommendations on who
you are not what you've done and we have
this real time component we have to
think about efficient algorithms and
like I said limited resources 8020
solutions are great anything that gets
stuff in front of users is great and we
don't have a giant team to invent new
wheels or anything like that so the
first decision is okay you know I came
in in 2017 what do we want to do first
so there was a recommender system that
was in production it's been built by
mostly software engineers and really
what it was was enhancements to the
search system that used a whole lot of
business logic based on the user's
profile to come up with a plausible set
of jobs that you might be interested in
didn't really have machine learning
it really wasn't great for a lot of
users it was impossible to iterate on it
was so tied to the details of the
implementation but it wasn't so bad that
it needed to be replaced immediately so
we did some other things first so the
first thing we really worked on was
trying to improve data quality so this
is obviously data engineering conference
I picked up a data engineer hat and
worked with our business analysts to
build a data warehouse to give them much
cleaner data source for pulling
historical information for pulling
information about jobs for playing
information about users interactions all
that together in a much much cleaner
system happy to tell you about that
later also spent a bunch of time working
on metrics so when I came in there was a
system but there was absolutely no way
to measure how well it was working so we
put in a bunch of features to to greatly
improve that system things like
taking snapshots when you apply to a job
to do really nice to know where that job
was in the hypothetical recommendations
list even if you came across in a
different way like search or an email
message with an invitation from a
business user or something like that
started calculating metrics technical
metrics things like the mean minimum log
rank which is sort of a variant of a
standard recommender system metric
basically that says you know how close
to the top of the rankings
are the things that you applied to
overall we also used to make more
business-friendly metrics I like this
sort of basically precision type of
thing what percent of users applied to
one or more of their top ten jobs over a
period of time this is very easy to
communicate unlike that that previous
one we set up an a/b testing framework
so allowed you know based on unuse your
ID different people to see different
variants of the existing system the
initial that initially had a bunch of
free parameters that we could tweak and
the the same system is in use with the
new recommender as well so once these
sort of foundational pieces were in
place it made sense to given everything
we've learned given that technology to
put everything else aside and start over
with a from scratch implementation of a
new recommendation system okay so I'm
gonna tell you a fair amount primarily
about the architecture to some extent
about the algorithms that we've put into
place I'm gonna start out with the the
real-time piece so that what happens
when after filling out your profile you
come to the jobs listing page for the
first time and get a set of jobs in in a
feed so kind of after deciding to go
ahead the next decision is what is the
architecture so the oral architecture
was this sort of monolith where the data
scientists who might want to try new
algorithms are gonna be working within
the main application framework and it
again was very tightly tied to the
existing elasticsearch implementation
which really strongly restricted what
was possible so the the decision was to
go ahead and totally separate build a
new micro service
build everything else from scratch and
this this has worked out pretty well so
to kind of walk you through what's
what's going on here
you know you come to this page and
essentially what you're you're telling
your web browsers like hey I'd like to
see some jobs now you have a user ID you
might have some other types of
information that you're kind of about
you about your user that goes to the
main application and says great that's
pretty hard though I don't really know
how to do that but I do know who you are
so it grabs your user profile
information from the database this is
obviously where this is stored the main
applications database constructs a
profile sends that to this micro service
that says ok I know how to do this I can
apply all of the feature engineering all
of the domain knowledge that data
scientists have about how to take this
profile turn it into something useful
that's where this happens the micro
Service has its own data sort that has
been previously set up by an offline
batch system sends back a list of ranked
listing IDs to the main application the
main application then pulls up
everything that the UI needs to actually
display those so things like the logo
and what have the UX people decided to
show up go on on the screen pulls all
that information and sends that to the
front end for display so why did we do
this this was a fair amount of new code
and the main reason is one of my
favorite things to harp on which is
separation of concerns so this is a
software architecture turn meaning that
each subsystem should be specialized and
subsystems shouldn't need to know about
the internals of other subsystems in
order to do their job so in this case
this means that the main application was
built by software engineers using their
tools and data scientists don't really
need to know what's going on they made
up that obviously knows about users and
all it has to do is it speaks its own
languages things like JSON objects polls
fields from the database took them
directly in this this object sends it
over the wire doesn't need to know about
feature engineering doesn't know it need
to know about algorithms the recommender
service on the other hand is built
tested and deployed by data science
machine learning engineer types of
persons and what it knows about in
general is job listings it knows what to
do with users but it doesn't store that
information the recommender system then
like I said parses that profile object
does feature in engineering and runs the
recommender algorithms and in addition
to then returning that to the main app
for display the recommender microservice
is very scalable in that it's basically
doing this one simple task can run a
bunch of copies of it there's no sort of
stored information that needs to be kept
in sync and this is great before dealing
with like peak periods or like when you
have to send recommendations to a
million people by email so that's the
high level sort of software architecture
I want to talk a little bit about the
algorithmic level particularly kind of
in the ways that apply to those
constraints that I started out so it's
pretty common in industry situations
where you're having to do this real-time
recommendation framework and you have a
lot of things to recommend if you only
have a thousand things to recommend
computers are pretty fast but when you
start having a hundred thousand a
million or more types of things to
recommend it's very common to have kind
of a two-step process where you do a
very fast quick rough algorithm to get
you to in our case down from like a
hundred thousand to maybe a thousand or
a hundred using whatever you got
heuristics some sort of learning that
can be scored really quickly and then
you can use whatever tricks you've got
up your sleeve to rewrite the top
hundred so maybe the thing that was
originally ranked 37 would be the thing
that the user is most likely to click on
and apply to you would really like to
use whatever fancy algorithms you've got
to make that that possible and so that's
the pattern that that we put into place
so let me kind of walk you through what
happens inside the recommender when it
receives this JSON blob with the profile
of a user so the first thing and there's
a bunch of arrows I'm gonna do my best
to kind of walk through this
so the first thing that happens is a
what we call a rough ranker applies so
this is a very fast not very precise
ranking system I'll talk a little bit
about the algorithm here in just a
moment and explain how and why as fast
one of the things that it does is it
takes the jobs that you have previously
interacted with or applied to and finds
other jobs that are similar using sort
of this secondary similarity algorithm
which I'm not going to go into detail on
all those things together come up with
this listing of let's say a thousand
jobs that you might be interested in
some sort of rough water some of these
which I've highlighted in yellow are way
up customer jobs some of them come from
other sources and then you want to take
the top let's say hundred of them and
rewrite them in this case hundred is
three I've just redefined it for today
and so you've got the original rough
ranking you've got this fine ray rancor
which I'll talk briefly about in a
minute and then we also and so maybe
that one decides that number twelve is
better than number seventeen and puts it
at the top and then we also have a thumb
on the scale piece which literally just
says if you're a way up job that's we
have customer job that's better than
being a distributor job that puts those
to the top then a pretty simple merging
algorithm use a kind of a weighted
approach to combine everything and grabs
the rest you know 101 to a thousand
grabs the rest of those listings puts
everything in it in an object and sends
it back to the domain application so
yeah we've got a Mart finery ranker and
a really stupid but smart from a
business perspective way of customer job
booster as well make sense so how do we
do this kind of rough ranking thing the
intuition here is that you can get
pretty close in a lot of cases just by
using tags so users you can take that
profile turn it into a big list of tags
listings you can grab metadata you can
grab text generate a whole bunch of tags
and to the extent that they overlap
that's pretty close to to matching now
of course we do a bunch
of you know heuristics business logic to
try and get this to work as good as
possible and so you end up with tags
like internship and so an internship
might be a tag that is a property of a
listing and you also know something
about hey this user is is you know still
in school so probably might be
interested in internships you create a
tag for that also you maybe you grabbed
from the skills listing Python maybe you
grabbed from the job description
description the word Python you can grab
major types of things as well and the if
you have previously stored some weights
from a machine learning system the
actual real-time scoring is as simple as
this very straightforward sequel query
it's just grouping by listing ID finding
the tags that overlap adding up the
weights and returning the top thousand
ratings and so this is something that
can be done in I don't know 100
milliseconds or something like that and
is a good start for generating the
recommendations the finery ranker I
don't want to go into too much detail on
it there are lots of ways to do this
Tony earlier kind of mentioned some of
them there's this general category of
algorithms called learning to rank you
can look at individual individual sort
of items you can look at whether pairs
are ordered correctly you can try and
figure out the come up with a loss
metric for the ranking of the entire
list in our case we're just doing right
now something really simple which is
estimating the probability of applying
given that you've seen the listing the
tricky part here if you think if you're
happen to be a data scientist you you're
thinking about this okay so historically
users have maybe applied to a half a
dozen jobs or something like that if
they're relatively active users but they
could have seen a hundred thousand right
so this is a wildly imbalanced problem
so a lot of the kind of tricks to
getting this to work are trying to find
a plausible set of jobs that they could
have applied to but didn't but not so
many that you have this wildly
imbalanced data set once you've done
that then you can apply a relatively
straightforward
off-the-shelf machine learning algorithm
in our case we used boosted trees tree
models are kind of nice just because
they tend to like you know like a linear
model like a regression model or
something tensed I'd like to add things
together but when trying to do this
matching problem you really kind of want
a more nonlinear types of thing just to
give an example of a way that sort of
the the tag the tag matching thing that
I used on the the the the rough rancor
doesn't work so think about a job for
you know an entry-level salesperson
right so you're looking for you know a
21 year old who's never had a sales job
before what in their resume says that
you're gonna want a sales job and
they're you're gonna be good at sales if
you've never done it before it's not
like a machine you know not like a data
scientist job let's say yeah a
mechanical engineer if your major is
mechanical engineering probably your job
title has the words mechanical
engineering in it sales is not like that
at all and probably the thing that is
you know a really good cue that you
might be interested in the sales job is
that you were not an engineer I for
example would be terrible at sales and
so this type of thing is much easier for
a nonlinear like a tree model to pick up
okay so that's most of what I want to
talk about at the algorithmic level what
about the implementation level and the
code we intentionally made this as
boring as possible again with a really
small team you don't have a lot of sort
of support to manage a custom set of
tools it's hard enough to deal with the
micro service and everything else so the
the stack though that we have in
production now so start out with Python
the main application way up com is a
Python app and so this is very handy
because now I can go to my colleagues
software engineers and be like help me
with this problem
look at this pull request even if you
don't understand the data science piece
you can at least understand the the
language and you know also there's
really good tools for machine learning
types of things in Python for the the
web layer the Web API we use flask this
was actually a change from what the
application uses which is Django Jenga
is a very heavyweight system for
building large websites that was wildly
overkill and using a very small system
made a lot more sense here much easier
much less for me to learn in terms of
database technologies and data
technologies off-the-shelf things like
sequel light off-the-shelf ways of
moving data around like s3 for the
machine learning components you know
scikit-learn linear models XG boost
spacey which is a relatively new but
quite extensively used natural language
processing system all of these used as
straightforwardly as possible to do
things like tag extraction weight
identification to find rear anchor and
so forth in terms of the actual
deployment you again using everything
totally standard with the rest of the
application framework building docker
images doing continuous integration and
testing dev staging and production
environments all the logging and
monitoring looks just like everything
else that the rest of the application
team is building and again with a really
small team don't have the resources to
do anything totally new and and
different so that was the real-time
piece I also want to talk a little bit
about kind of everything else that goes
around so you know in data science 90%
of the work is you know massaging the
data and feature engineering in in
production machine learning engineering
actually only 1% is the fun stuff 9% is
the data and 90% is everything else that
you build to actually get the thing into
production and so one of the things to
get right is what happens when so I told
you about the real-time thing where in
real time you're generating these tags
for users and doing other types of
processing the boosting the query the
re-ranking with the fancy algorithm on
the manual side so maybe once every
three months that kind of thing you
probably want to rebuild the ranking
algorithm or so yeah we rebuild
everything so the world doesn't change
job listings don't change that often
you don't really need to change things
too much unless you're changing the
algorithm itself so basically rebuilding
everything from scratch probably should
do every once in a while and whenever
you're able to add heuristics add new
features we have a process for doing
that where you can sort of test and make
sure that everything is working well but
it's important to have the data
scientist in the loop during that part
of the process
this said there are things you have to
do pretty close to real time so new jobs
come in all the time and you'd really
like to rank them or recommend them
whenever they're available so
twice-daily we have a system that pulls
whatever listings are now active from a
database generates tags and and waits
for those using pre learned weights and
save some artifacts for the real time
system to pick up and in terms of the
rough ranker which I described before
the component to the batch processing
task looks roughly like this so kind of
orchestrated by airflow we have this ETL
process which is going on to support the
data warehouse and other things but also
data products like this there's a
listing tag generator that pulls the tag
weights out of and as three artifact
which had been previously stored and
then push it builds a sequel light
database for real-time scoring that gets
dropped into s3 so whenever a real-time
scoring system grabs that sequel light
database that has an up-to-date set of
job listings that I can recommend okay
so on top of that there's all this other
stuff that you want to build I really
want to talk about this pattern because
I think it's really important and I've
done this several times and it has been
unbelievably valuable so when building a
predictive model or a recommendation
system sure one of the way so you can
see whether it's working is you can turn
it on and look at the main you know web
app screen and see if you get some
recommendations that look pretty good
but that's not enough it makes a huge
difference if you can build api's to
allow you as a data scientist as a
machine lean machine learning engineer
to build a system that gives you an
alternative debugging interactive
a system for looking at in this case it
looking at recommendations so I built an
app in China the are based web tool
system framework that can hit the API
the main API the from the recommender
service either in production or in
staging or in a local machine can do the
main scoring tasks so give me the job
for this particular user but it could
also do other things so I'd like tell me
about this job just give me the the tags
back not the recommendations tell me
about yourself what version are you when
we were last updated all that kind of
thing very useful to have access to that
also it was useful for the main
application to have a an API endpoint
that goes the other way so usually the
application takes the user data from the
database builds a profile object and
sends it to the recommender service it's
also useful to have an endpoint for me
to pull that says hey tell me about user
you know a thousand and four and get
that profile information that gives me a
lot of information about an opportunity
to kind of you know play with that
request in real time and explore what's
going right and what's going wrong and
of course it's also useful to have
access to some sort of database so I can
see much more information about a user
or a job listing that might not be an
either source as contextual information
and this was unbelievably useful for
debugging and to make sure that the
system was working to look at staging
versions before they're in production
and so forth highly highly recommend
this pattern so I mentioned a little bit
earlier about a be testing and metrics
and tuning so obviously a lot of machine
learning is having happening offline
here but there are also lots of
parameters you know all the weights for
how to combine things lots of other
types of real time things that you can
play with and so it's really important
to have an a/b testing framework that
lets you get two good metrics and good
baby testing so to kind of walk you
through how that works
suppose you are user number three and
you've clicked the box or the drop-down
that says I'm really interested in
part-time jobs right now on
on the front end of the website that
gets sent to the application the
application at this point does something
that is pretty useful so you probably
familiar with the idea of like a session
on a on a website that's usually minutes
or hours long we have a another type of
session that we generate inside the
application which is the context for a
particular set of recommendations so
when you do this query we generate a
discovery session which has some ID it
also has you know what test bucket
you're in so your user 3 was assigned to
test buggy and B in this case also has
any other parameters that were applied
to generate the listings the application
then generates the JSON blob sends it to
the recommender service recommender
sends back a bunch of listings the
application adds that context discovery
app session ID to that set of listings
sent it to the front-end the reason we
do this is because we use a lot of sort
of JavaScript tracking things as really
nice to have that piece of data
available all the way through the event
tracking process so that's kind of the
the back and forth loop as this is going
on other types of artifacts are being
generated so the you know the database
stores these discovery sessions the logs
have things like you know user 3 clicked
on this listing at a point in time in
this particular session at position 1 on
the screen and again that's amazing data
to have if the user clicks the apply
button we also as I said earlier collect
a snapshot so we know what position in a
hypothetical set of job recommendations
so this is not storing what they saw
this is storing what they would have
seen if they had nothing clicked so
they're kind of default recommendations
and if they had scrolled for like you
know 10 minutes so he's throwing lots
and lots of these we get these kind of
counterfactual job listings that they
could have seen could have applied to
MIT but but didn't and when you take all
these pieces of data and combine them
you can get some really nice clean data
for maybe tests things like users in
bucket
32% of them applied to a listing in
their top ten over a period of time
maybe it's higher in bucket beat which
is great but you also want to look at
other types of metrics so like what
proportion of users applied to a job
during this during the time that the
test was in effect and maybe that's a
smaller change than the actual
improvement in the sort of technical
metric of how high in the
recommendations were the applied to jobs
cool so all these pieces are necessary
to get to the this data so to kind of
wrap things up with some thoughts I want
to talk a little bit about the impact so
because of the metrics and the a/b tests
and everything else that we had built at
the beginning before putting the new
recommender system into place we knew
the old recommender system was not
consistently as good as we wanted it to
be anecdotal sort of qualitative
evidence said the same thing and we also
knew that some of the business metrics
things like applications to their
customer jobs needed some love and
attention which is why we decided to
build this in the first place and so
when we rolled out the new system over
the summer we used a B testing along the
way to try and evaluate how much this
was was helping and got some pretty good
results so in when the very first
version of this was deployed we were
able to do an a/b test with it's kind of
like then not quite a minimum but pretty
not not fully fleshed out not fully
tuned version of the system I just
described
compared to that previous system it led
to a 20% increase in applications so
that was great and really compelling as
we did other types of tuning just to
give an example the addition of the fine
rear anchor which I described was not in
the initial version just because we
wanted to get it out the door
that also led to a further boost so the
the sort of the the the sense of am I
getting recommended things that I
actually want to apply to that increased
by 20% and for customer jobs that
application rate also rose by 5% which
is nothing to sneeze at
we've done a variety of other a B tests
as well and continue to tune the system
those types of systems also tend to you
know end up with like 5% increases for
any given parameter that where they were
trying to - so really important to have
the the metrics and testing framework as
well as the you know the system itself
should be ideally pretty good
so kind of stepping back you know we
were able to build this recommender
system focused on a very specific
experience the experience of that new
user who just filled out a profile so
real-time matching based rather than
collaborative based or experience based
a system that incorporates the business
goals as well as user goals sort of
combines them in the best way possible
really happy with the architecture with
the micro-service this two-step system
which scales quite well also very happy
with the technology choices extremely
happy with the decision to build testing
and metrics first able to demonstrate
value as well as continue to tune and in
terms of ongoing support and maintenance
and Inter ability the fact that we've
got these as a totally separate micro
service means that you know whoever is
working on this next it way up is going
to be able to very quickly make changes
deploy them and test them quite easily
the said it's still a fairly complicated
system but I think it we made the
decision to build this fairly
complicated system for good reasons
having to do with the the business
constraints the site design constraints
the scaling constraints the resource
constraints and so forth so thank you
what questions do you have
[Applause]
and
yes the logging is primarily not done by
the microservice so the main application
knows what listings were recommended
because it had to like look things up
and put them on the screen there were a
couple of special pieces that were built
things like that snapshot system that's
like a little trigger that when you
apply to a job it says okay when did you
apply
strictly before that point in time what
would the recommendations have been been
that have been generated that's like
kind of like an offline thing that was
built by the engineers the actual logs
from the recommender itself are not as
useful actually as putting them in
context with everything else yeah I mean
it's still good to have logs on a
production system so you can see when it
breaks and look at you know timing and
things like that but yeah it's mostly
through the main application
yes
right so the the primary primary
learning processes happen offline run by
a data scientist in a sort of manual but
workflow design process and like I said
that that doesn't need to happen very
often
the part that happens in real-time only
includes a tiny bit of machine learning
which is like the similarity sub model
which I didn't talk about does because
the set of job listings change you kind
of need to do that in real-time but
everything else is done offline imagine
so the only thing that's happening on
this sort of twice-daily process is just
taking the things that you've learned
and applying them to the such that you
can do the the real-time processing very
quickly
[Music]